THAT'S NOT THE ONLY THING
HAPPENING IN WASHINGTON
TONIGHT.
LESS THAN 48 HOURS AGO,
IMPEACHMENT SEEMED LIKE A
REMOTE POSSIBILITY.
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE WAS NOT
FOR IT.
JOE BIDEN THE LEADING
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE HAD
NOT COME OUT IN FAVOR OF IT.
NOW, JUST A COUPLE DAYS
LATER IT LOOKS ALMOST
CERTAIN.
WHY?
NOT BECAUSE WE HAVE LEARNED
ANYTHING NEW ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE NOT.
WE HAVE NOT FOUND A NEW
PROBE OF COMPROMISING
DOCUMENTS.
THERE IS NO BLURRY iPHONE
VIDEO IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT
SWEARS TO VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THAT INFORMATION IS PROBABLY
NOT GOING TO EMERGE BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T EXIST AND NEVER
HAS DESPITE YEARS OF
INVESTIGATIONS AND MANY
MILLIONS SPENT TRYING TO
FIND IT.
NOBODY HAS FOUND ANY
EVIDENCE THAT THE PRESIDENT
INCLUDED WITH RUSSIA IN
ORDER TO WIN THE 2016
ELECTION.
DOESN'T MATTER THOUGH ROBERT
MUELLER DELIVERED A
STATEMENT YESTERDAY WHICH
WHICH HE SAID I COULDN'T
PROVE THE PRESIDENT
COMMITTED A CRIME BUT I ALSO
COULDN'T PROVE HE DIDN'T
COMMIT A CRIME.
ON THE BASIS OF THAT,
SUDDENLY, DEMOCRATS APPEAR
TO BE UNITED TONIGHT.
WE MUST IMPEACH.
>> ANYBODY WHO LOOKS AT THE
POLITICS OF THIS, IT'S A
THORNY PATH.
BUT I THINK HISTORY IS GOING
TO LOOK BACK AT THIS MOMENT
AND WHAT WE CHOOSE TO DO AND
SEE IF WE DID THE RIGHT
THING.
AND I THINK THE RIGHT THING
RIGHT NOW IS TO HOLD THIS
PRESIDENT ACCOUNTABLE FOR
HIS ACTIONS.
>> WE HAVE TO GET THE SHOW
ON THE ROAD.
WE HAVE TO HAVE THESE
INVESTIGATIONS DONE ON TV
UNDER THE MANNER OF
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
WAY AROUND THAT MAKE
EVERYBODY VOTE.
MAKE HERB IN THE HOUSE VOTE.
SEND IT OVER TO THE SENATE.
MAKE THEM VOTE.
PUT THEM ON THE RECORD AND
MAKE THEM LIVE WITH THOSE
VOTES FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES.
>> IMPEACHMENT IS A PROCESS,
NOT A THING.
THEY NEED TO MOVE TOWARD IT
STRATEGICALLY AND THEY NEED
TO MAKE SURE THEY ARE
BRINGING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ALONG WITH THEM.
>> I WOULD SUGGEST THAT HE
TOLD US ENOUGH TO INTERPRET
WHAT HE SAID AS A REFERRAL
FOR IMPEACHMENT.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS A PARADE
OF DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS
MOSTLY DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES AND
ONE FAKE REPUBLICAN.
SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE CONTEXT
AND LEVEL HEADED CONTEXT OF
WHAT THIS MIGHT MEAN.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WEE HAVE
GOTTEN THE LAST TWO DAYS.
INSTEAD UNENDING STRING OF
HYPERBOLE AND HYSTERICS.
>> WE BEGIN WITH A LITANY OF
LIES FROM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES ONE DAY
AFTER SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER AGAIN BUT THIS TIME
ON CAMERA EXPLAINED HE DID
NOT CLEAR THE PRESIDENT OF A
CRIME.
>> A PRESIDENT WHO
THEORETICALLY CAN BREAK ANY
LAW HE WANTS GOING FORWARD
SO LONG AS 34 SENATORS
DECIDE TO STICK WITH HIM.
>> MUELLER DID NOT SAY THE I
WORD, I DON'T THINK ANYONE
WAS BRACING FOR THAT TODAY.
THAT'S NOT HOW BOB MUELLER
ROLLS.
>> HE CONSIDERS THIS AN
EMERGENCY.
HE CONSIDERS THIS A VERY
SERIOUS EFFORT BY RUSSIA TO
IRCHT FEAR WITH OUR
ELECTION, THAT IT HAPPENED
AND THAT IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> Tucker: A LITANY OF LIE
AND EMERGENCY.
A PRESIDENT WHO CAN BREAK
ANY LAW.
IF YOU ARE THAT EXCITED, GO
AHEAD AND IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
DEMOCRATS RAN LAST YEAR ON
HEALTHCARE AND INCOME
INEQUALITY.
THINGS THAT VOTERS APPEAR TO
BE INTERESTED IN.
HOW EXCITED WILL VOTERS BE
TO SEE THE NEXT YEAR AND A
HALF BLOWN ON AN IMPEACHMENT
TRIAL THAT WILL NOT SUCCEED,
WASTE TIME AND MONEY AND
ACHIEVE NOTHING?
IT MIGHT BE INTERESTING TO
FIND OUT, ACTUALLY.
PELOSI MAY BE EXTREME BUT
SHE IS NOT STUPID.
THERE'S A REACH THAT SHE HAS
BEEN AGAINST IMPEACHMENT
FROM DAY ONE.
SHE KNOWS IT WILL HURT HER
OWN PARTY.
HER PARTY DOESN'T CARE.
SO, GO AHEAD.
IMPEACH HIM.
UNTIL THEN LET'S ADMIT
ANOTHER FACT.
ROBERT MUELLER'S SPEECH
YESTERDAY SAID A LOT MORE
ABOUT HIM AND HIS
INVESTIGATION THAN IT DID
THE SUBJECT OF HIS
INVESTIGATION.
IN HIS REMARKS YESTERDAY
MUELLER SAID IT WAS
IMPORTANT THAT, QUOTE:  THE
OFFICE'S WRITTEN WORK SPEAK
FOR ITSELF.
THE WRITTEN WORK, OF COURSE,
IS HIS REPORT.
WE HAVE HAD THAT FOR A MONTH
AND OBVIOUSLY IT DIDN'T
JUSTIFY IMPEACHMENT.
SO MUELLER DECIDED TO SPEAK
UP AND TIP THE SCALES IN A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
THAT WAS THE POINT OF
YESTERDAY'S COMMENTS.
HE SAID HE WAS UNABLE TO
EXONERATE THE PRESIDENT OF
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
IT'S UP TO CONGRESS TO
DECIDE WHAT TO DO.
OF COURSE, IN A FAIR
SOCIETY.
IN ALL FAIR SOCIETIES,
PROSECUTORS NEVER EXONERATE
PEOPLE.
PROSECUTORS EITHER CHARGE
PEOPLE WITH CRIMES OR THEY
LEAVE THEM ALONE.
PROSECUTORS ARE NOT SUPPOSED
TO RELEASE EMBARRASSING
MATERIAL ABOUT PRIVATE
CITIZENS UNLESS IT DIRECTLY
RELATES TO A CRIMINAL
OFFENSE.
LIKE SO MANY OTHER PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON THOUGH, MUELLER
AND HIS TEAM FORGOT THAT
BASIC PRINCIPLE AND SO
THANKS TO THEIR WORK OUR
COUNTRY WILL BE SUFFERING
THROUGH ANOTHER YEAR OF
POINTLESS POLITICAL THEATER
WHILE THE NEW PROBLEMS
FESTER AND GET WORSE.
OPIOIDS, STUDENT LOANS, THE
BORDER CHINA.
TAKE YOUR PICK.
THERE ARE SO MANY.
NONE OF THOSE WILL GET